تقدم اوكراني في معارك الجبهه الشرقيه وان
كان بوتيره بطيئه بلده بث الاوكرانيون
منها هذه الصور معلنين استعادتها وانهاء
السيطره الروسيه عليها هذه البلله الصغيره
جنوب غربي حدود مقاطعه زبالوجيا هي البلده
التاسعه التي استعادها الاوكرانيون في
الاسابيع الاخيره تقول نائبه وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني ان قواتهم نفذت هجوما مضاده
خلال اسبوع في عده محاور وحققت تقدما في
كل اتجاه يراوح بين كيلو متر وكيلو مترين
بمساحه قدرتها ب130 كيلومترا مربعا
الروايه الروسيه المقابله من وزاره الدفاع
تحدثت بدورها عن صد الهجمات الاوكرانيه
شرقا وتكميد قواتها خسائر كبيره في الجنود
والعتاد جنوبا يبرز تمكن الاوكرانيين من
العبور الى الضفه اليمنى لنهر دينيبر
تطورا لافتا وسابقا من نوعه منذ تراجع
الروسي باتجاه هذه الضفه في مقاطعه خرسون
نهايه العام الماضي عبور نهر دنيبر يعطي
الاوكرانيين طرقا مختصره في حال تامين
الضفتين في منطقه ما وانشائهم جسورا تعبر
منها القوات نهر دنيبر الفاصل والعائق
الطبيعي بين الطرفين عندها تصبح المواجهه
مباشره اكثر بعدما كان الاوكرانيون يركزون
على استهداف الخطوط الخلفيه للقوات
الروسيه الروايه الروسيه ذكرت ان مجموعات
اوكرانيه صغيره حاولت عبور النهر بالقوارب
الا ان قواتهم استهدفتها ودمرتها ومع
التركيز الاوكراني ثم يطلق عليه الهجوم
المضاد جنوبا وشرقا وتقدمهم على حساب
الروسي وفق ما يقولون ما زال الميدان يقبل
احتمالات كثيره وربما كبيره اذ ظهر وزير
الدفاع الروسي متفقدا احد المواقع في
رساله بعوده التركيز العسكري الروسي على
ما يحدث في اوكرانيا بعد الانشغال داخليا
لوقت قصير كما ان وسائل اعلام روسيه بثت
صورا قالت انها لمقاتلي مجموعه فاجنر في
مقاطعه لوغانس باوكرانيا عقب انسحابها من
الاراضي الروسيه